[Music]
good morning
from winter where the funeral of prince
philip is taking place
later today an unwavering loyalty to the
queen
country and commonwealth is how the duke
of edinburgh will be remembered at the
service
soldiers will line the route to st
george's chapel where a group of 30 led
by the queen will pay
their last respects our all
correspondent rhiannon mills reports
relaxed and at ease this is how the
queen will remember her dedicated
consort
releasing one of her favorite
photographs of prince philip
as she prepares to say goodbye it will
be in the ornate setting of saint
george's chapel that her majesty will
sit alone
amongst reminders of the duke one of
only 30
in the congregation due to covet making
it an intimate family service
the archbishop of canterbury who's
involved in the ceremony
says the duke was determined to make his
mark on this final farewell
he was involved in every detail of it
it is meticulously planned for over a
quarter of a century and
when the order of service is seen his
imprint will be
all over it and he didn't want to fuss
and he knew exactly what he wanted and
it was thoughtful and i think that
people
listening to this service watching it on
the tv
will find it speaks very deeply to their
own hearts his influence couldn't be
clearer in the order of service
among the music chosen the jubilate
written for st
george's chapel at prince philip's
request
he also asked for psalm 104 to be set to
music
at the end of the service the buglers of
the royal marines will not only sound
the last post but also
action stations a call to action in the
royal navy
there will be no eulogy or readings from
the family but they're not usually a
feature
of royal funerals the unique touches
will be visible from the start
of the procession from the land rover he
helped to design
to his ponies and carriage on display as
his coffin
is driven away a truly unforgettable
character that his children have so
fondly remembered this week princess
anne's former private secretary says his
influence
as a father was clear they they
certainly shared i think many of the
same
same characteristics i mean a real
sense of a real sense of duty uh
and uh and just get on with the
with with the job in hand you know work
hard
don't expect too many thanks uh and
and just do the job to the best of your
ability
inside the grounds prince edward the
council of wessex
and their daughter lady louise had come
to see the flowers
left outside of the castle moved during
the week
and placed next to st george's chapel
covid has meant that the royal family
haven't been able to come out and thank
people
in the ways that they would have wanted
but the fact that they are still
allowing cameras in for this very close
family funeral
shows a genuine desire to allow others
to share
in this moment of mourning for a
dedicated consort
and a man that they loved very much
they're asking people not to come to
windsor and instead join them in a
minute silence from their own homes
we live quite quite local here so we
come quite often and it's really
the mood is different he's done a lot
for our country which actually
i've only realized in the last week
ahead of the funeral these were the
images the family wanted to share
prince philip the father and grandfather
faithful supporter of his wife and queen
always looking down on her as they
prepare
to remember him
well rhiannon joins me now here at
winter castle um
uh rhiannon the thing that that that i
think is is the loveliest thing so far
today is the picture that they've
released of
of the queen and prince philip up about
moral we've seen so many photographs
haven't we this week
of prince philip philippine maybe his
military regalia or
carrying out those official duties with
the queen and yet when it came to
that moment that her majesty we haven't
heard from her this week but
she obviously wanted to to share
something with us and
we got that rather informal photograph
of them
um on holiday in scotland um prince
philip relaxing back the queen's smiling
and i think it gives that sense of the
man that
she will be remembering today the man
behind the scenes that maybe we didn't
get to see
all that often yes we got to see his
cheeky side but
uh we didn't necessarily get to see
those intimate family moments and and
that's something that has really come
across this week
is with all their family tributes they
have been so warm
and so affectionate in a way that i
probably didn't anticipate
and it's sort of been so we've had seen
a lot more of the royal family this week
than i would have ever expected
i think it was important for them to
come out and pay their tributes
especially at a time when
they can't come out and thank members of
the public for for leaving flowers so i
think in a way
um they have wanted to put those
messages out there for example the
prince of wales
last weekend um giving a message on the
doorstep at highgrove
messages from the family and in a sense
they have i think
lifted the veil a bit on relationships
between the family
they really are showing that today will
be about yes
celebrating his amazing achievements but
also marking
the man and not the post and while we
will talk about his
his dedicated service and duty this was
ultimately
a father a grandfather and a husband
having said that rhiannon when we look
at the service uh
there won't be family members standing
up and speaking
and i think some people will be
surprised by that um for the palace it
was important to share
the order of service because ultimately
they're asking people not to come here
to windsor
so they're hoping people at home can to
re can read along in a way with the
order of service but yeah there is no
eulogy there are no family readings
we're told that that is fairly
traditional for royal funerals but we
know that prince philip has tried to
shake things up a little bit when it
comes to
to his own farewell and in some ways
they could have included
family readings but in a way maybe is he
protecting them from
further spotlight we know that the
cameras are inside the chapel today
it's going to be a very poignant moment
when we see her majesty the queen
and maybe it was decided that actually
this is not necessarily a moment that
the family need to stand up
and publicly um speak um instead i think
the service the way it's been put
together will speak volumes
um rhiannon will be talking to you lots
more throughout the morning
i'm sure thanks very much for now
well while the funeral service will take
place at three o'clock a procession will
begin
before that this is how events will
unfold
at just after 20 to 3 the duke of
edinburgh's coffin will be carried from
the state entrance of windsor castle
the queen's company first battalion
grenadier guards will place the coffin
on a specially modified land rover which
prince philip helped design
at 2 45 the procession will set off led
by the chiefs of the armed forces and
other
senior military figures it will pass to
the north side of the round
tower followed on foot by the prince of
wales and other members of the royal
family
the queen will be driven in the state
bentley
the route will be lined with
representatives drawn from the royal
navy
royal marines the highlanders 4th
battalion royal regiment and the royal
air force
minute guns will be fired from the east
lawn of the castle by the king's royal
horse
artillery and the bells of the curfew
tower will toll
the rifles regiment will provide a guard
of honour and band to play the national
anthem
as the coffin enters horseshoe cloister
before coming to a stop at the foot of
the chapel's west steps
at 2 53 the royal marines bearer party
will carry the coffin to the chapel
porch
where it will pause at 3 p.m when a
national minute's
silence will be held the dean of windsor
and the archbishop of canterbury will
then receive prince philip's coffin in
the chapel
and the service will begin the
congregation instant george's chapel
will be made up of 30 people with the
queen
likely to be sitting alone to meet
social distancing rules
a small choir of four people will sing
pieces of music chosen by the duke of
edinburgh
there will be no congregational singing
at the end of the service
prince philip's coffin will be lowered
into the royal vault beneath
the chapel choir
well although today's royal funeral has
been scaled back because of current
virus restrictions we will still see a
formal military
send off for the duke of edinburgh let's
talk now
to the lieutenant general david leakey
who organized many state occasions when
he served as black rod
at the palace of westminster good to
talk to you this morning
um these kind of events
they are long in the planning aren't
they uh what are we going on do you
think
this morning you're right they are long
in the planning
and the the plan which uh the duke of
edinburgh himself drew up for his own
funeral
um has of course been significantly
adapted because of the
coronavirus um and the restrictions and
measures around it
and and so the plan that we're seeing
today
is in many ways very very different to
the one the one that's been
on the books and has been tweaked and
modified um
by both staff by the military the police
the security
uh to the one that we see today but um
the plan will have been very very
carefully thought through
every last detail all the drill
movements for the military
they will have been rehearsed and i
think one of the things that people
don't often know
is the amount of preparation not just on
the visible ceremonial that you
see um on the on the television pictures
that you're
looking now i mean there's a rehearsals
with people not wearing all the full
uniforms
and undress rehearsals as it were but
also
all the administrative arrangements
behind that because many of the
servicemen taking part
in the ceremonial today they will have
been
um engaged in fact programmed to be
doing
other things at this time so some will
have been on operations
um in the recent past others will have
been planned to be out on
training exercises because as the duke
himself will have known
the military is the 24 7 operation and
and so people will have been adapted and
flexed flexed away from what they were
supposed to be doing
to come and do this and do this
willingly by the way
uh the servicemen are incredibly proud
of
uh owing their allegiance to
uh the queen to the royal family above
all
uh and you talk about the fact that it
is long in the planning uh the little
chamber and william peale who's overseen
uh the organization and planning of this
um
has just retired uh handing over the
reins to andrew parker
will he still be involved do you think i
mean it it seems extraordinary to think
that that something you've planned for
all this time
which happens a week after you retire
that you won't have an involvement
well um earl peels um
the hallmark of oil peel will be stamped
all over this plan
um as with a lot of other people um
and and in fact uh i remember when i
retired as black rod
and and i was responsible for the
all the planning for for example the
queen's lying in state
in westminster hall should shouldn't
when as and it will be
when that moment ever happens that she
dies and she lies in state
when i retired i handed over all those
plans to my successor
we had a very good i had a very good
deputy who
actually probably knew more of the
detail on some parts of the plans than
even i did so i think you'll find that
in these things the succession
and the handover of these plans and the
contingency arrangements is always there
but just as my successor as black rod
occasionally rings me up to to
interrogate the corporate memory
i'm sure that there's been there have
been some phone calls between
uh the two lord chamberlain's the
present one and the recently retired
you of course met uh the queen and the
duke
what are your memories of them
um always um always very happy
memories i think one of the uh one of
the things which um
i remember having to brief uh on a
number of occasions
um groups of people who are about to
meet
the queen and the duke and uh
one of the things i i always remember
saying to them is
um you probably remember the queen when
you see her very often on the television
programs and the duke 2
they walk in and they quite often have a
rather serious almost
stern look on their face um and that's
because
um they're probably taxing their
corporate their their briefing memory of
the briefing notes who they're meeting
next what what they should be saying
particularly diplomatic occasions
and um what and i always brief people
what will happen
next is the queen will look up and she
will look at you
and the duke too and they will look at
you and
suddenly they will smile and when they
smile
it's like someone's turned all the
television lighting on in the studio
it's bright and illuminated and
and you will just feel relaxed because
they want you to be relaxed
and when they talk to people one-to-one
face-to-face
face-to-face close-up they're very
relaxed
and they listen very carefully which is
why the duke of course was
always one for quipping back because
people would say things perhaps
spontaneously perhaps not having
fully thought them through caught in the
moment you might say
and the duke would quit back very very
quickly because he was listening
and uh and he would fire you a question
that would take you unawares
and immediately the atmosphere would
become
informal but above all spontaneous and
people could be
themselves he had that extraordinary
knack
of of relaxing people to be themselves
and and when we look at what's happening
today obviously because of covert a very
small number of people attending
this funeral just the the number of 30.
right decision do you think for the
prime minister not to attend
well i it's not for me to decide whether
it is or isn't the right decision for
the prime minister that's one for him
but i think it is a it is a very family
very family affair and um i i'm sure
there will be
other occasions when um there can be
perhaps recognition in a different
setting for for the life of the duke
um but i think in a way
our thoughts should not be about um the
politics and the political persona
around this um and indeed
i could see sort of complications if the
prime minister was there
then why not the leader of the
opposition and the leaders of other
political parties
and uh actually when
when when when great figures
die very often there is a funeral
just for the family because this is
after all
that last moment when a family gets to
say
farewell to a family member and
i can remember my father's own funeral
he was a general
um and we had a funeral for family and
friends
and yes there were some other military
people there
who came but not representatives from
all the
charities and regimental associations
and so on that he had represented
they came to the memorial service so the
funeral was very much for us
a family and friends event and i think
that will be the same
and what matters very very much to the
queen
as you can see from the photographs she
was very
family oriented and so was the duke and
i think
our thoughts today should be with the
queen and for her
immediate supporting family around her
david leahy a former black rod good to
talk to you thank you very much
well our correspondent aleister bunkel
is with me here at windsor castle
uh and alistair um david nicky they're
talking about the fact that a lot of
people won't be at the funeral because
of the size and because it is a family
event but
there will be a lot of military here
throughout the day won't they
representing uh different units that the
prince was associated with
730 military personnel so we talk of a
small and intimate funeral uh it is
by ceremonial funeral standards but
there will be a large military
contingent here and actually i think
because of the absence
of uh foreign dignitaries and heads of
government
ambassadors extended family the sort of
people who would attend
if it were not in covet times the focus
on the military will be even greater
uh their role will be even more
impactful than it would have otherwise
been now
like so many they have been planning
this funeral
for years and years and years they've
been revising it tweaking a little bit
they knew that if something were to
happen if he were to pass drink
overtimes
they would need to shrink it back and
sort of strip out a number of the
elements they're thought of
so as you'd expect with the military not
only do they do an awful lot of planning
the entire time
but they're pretty well rehearsed as
well and they've been making sure the
last couple of days i've watched it
that they are getting it absolutely step
perfect and i'm sure it will go right on
the day
sure it will alastair thanks very much
well just a reminder that full coverage
of prince philip's funeral will take
place here on sky news we'll have
a special program today from 12 30
they'll also be live coverage from
2 40 on sky one
well let's take a look at the front
pages of the papers this morning lots of
them
are focusing on today's event here
the times previews prince philip's
funeral with the simple headline
the queen bids farewell
the mirror's headline farewell my love
the sun says farewell my prince
the express offers its support to the
queen declaring
always there for you mom
the mail looks ahead to today's funeral
saying one last moment with her prince
the telegraph quotes from remarks
expected to be given by
the dean of windsor as he conducts the
service
with grateful hearts we remember the
many ways in which a long
life his long life has been a blessing
to us
and prince philip's legacy is reflected
on front pages across the country
including here in the yorkshire post
meanwhile the eye reports the pregnant
women on next on the priority list for
the covert vaccine
and that is also the lead story for the
guardian
the financial times has more on the
david cameron
lobbying row
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other
news now and as we're just saying on the
front of those papers pregnant women
could be offered the covert jab as
normal
and should be according to britain's top
scientists the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization has said it
would like them to be given
the pfizer and moderna vaccines at the
same time as people in their age group
a look at the latest coronavirus figures
2596 new cases have been reported with
34 more deaths which brings the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of a positive test
to 127 255.
another 129 782
have received their first vaccine and
thousand six 417.6 and eighty-three
people have received their second dose
which means that nearly 4.5 million jabs
have now been given out
across the uk
a leading scientist has told sky news
that the prime minister should cancel
his trip to india next week
a new variant of coronavirus which has
also been detected in britain is being
blamed for a huge rise
in the number of new cases there
a protest has been held in chicago after
the police shooting of a 13 year old boy
adam toledo was shot once in the chest
by an officer in late march
moments after dropping a handgun and
raising his arms
protesters have called for the officer
who fatally shot adam toledo to face
charges for the first time in 62 years
the leader of
cuba will not be called castro raul
castro last night resigned as head of
the ruling communist party
the 89 year old and his brother fidel
held power since the revolution
in 1959.
let's get a look at today's weather now
with nas
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we're looking at mostly
fine and settled conditions across
the vast majority of the uk and island
once again for today thanks to
high pressure still firmly in charge
it's a
chilly start once again though with
fairly frosty conditions out there as
well
one or two isolated patches of mist and
fog otherwise
it's dry and sunny perhaps a little less
cold across the far northwest where it's
cloudy and breezy
and through today we'll see little
change on that story really we'll
continue with lots of sunshine a lot of
dry weather
a bit of fair weather cloud bubbling up
here and there may be turning that
sunshine hazy at times but
all in all it's looking fine and uh
temperatures tiny bit below average for
time of year but
we could see them slightly higher than
yesterday locally up to around 15 or 16
possible
later though we are seeing cloudier
skies develop across western ireland
western scotland too it will become
breezier across these areas with rain
over western ireland by this evening
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
thanks very much nas now prince philip
has been a high-profile public figure
from the day he became
engaged to the then princess elizabeth
in 1947.
martha kellner has been speaking to the
longest-serving royal photographer
anwar hussein who's traveled more than
50 000 miles
to more than 70 countries alongside the
royal couple
anwar hussein began an extraordinary
life behind the lens photographing rock
stars and film stars
but the ultimate celebrity family became
his life's work
for more than half a century royal tours
took him to nauru nepal new zealand
and everywhere in between capturing the
queen
and at her side or in the background but
always there
was the duke of edinburgh it's an
extraordinary life that he lived
and you were living it right alongside
him
yeah all the color around the world
as one of the royal family's favored
photographers anwar was given license to
capture them in more private moments
he didn't like other photographers he
he'd rather tell them
he never told me he always used to say
oh you are still at it
yeah he had a wicked sense of your mind
he's credited with helping transform
their image from stiff and stuffy
to relaxed and relatable the queen liked
this picture of the family in montreal
in 1976
so much she made it an official
christmas card they were there to watch
princess anne compete at the olympics
it was an unusual normal
a royal family goes away they leave
somebody ahead
behind and this time they
they all went but i told them
that i wanted this the first time he's
dreaming man you've never been out of
the country
and we've got to have this picture and
we must recall
the stage of what do you have to answer
he was also on hand to witness the
vulnerable moments of the queen and her
husband
in morocco they were in the desert and
they
they had to sit down on the floor and
and have
a lime roasted lamb eat with their hands
and you can see the picture the duke is
very awake and son
and looking at the queen for the silver
jubilee tour in 1977
anwar travelled 80 000 kilometers
alongside the royal couple
duke and queen like that cultural
dancing
and celebration of the
ways of living and everything like that
and also he's quite fascinated about
seeing men in grass skirts and things
like that
you know they used to have a joke with
them you know i don't know whether he
was
pulling the leg or whether they
understood his sense of humor
he was known as being quite direct oh
yeah he was terribly direct
absolutely and
especially with local people he used to
you know save all sorts of things like
that
and go to everything prince philip was
most relaxed spending time on the water
at the balmoral estate
or carriage driving which replaced polo
as his sport of choice
i think he quite like the uh
where where didn't have to wear uniform
they quite like
being overseas outside their own friends
and family
there's nobody who has spent more time
with the royals
up close and personal martha kellner
sky news chippenham
well we are of course going to have much
more on prince philip's funeral
throughout the day here on sky news
preparations
now happening inside windsor castle
behind us here and also
in the wider area although people here
in windsor are being asked
not to come down to the castle to mark
the princess passing
at home well welcome back to windsor
castle
the funeral of the duke of edinburgh is
to take place this afternoon marks the
end of an extraordinary
and privileged life the service will
reflect aspects of his long service
and often low-key lifestyle or we're
joined by the british historian sir
anthony himself and
to reflect more uh on prince philip and
his life and
uh so sir anthony you you've written a
piece about how he was a clearly devoted
husband distinguished military man
very hard working but why do you think
he was
remarkable because of the length of
service
the longest consort in british history
and because he was married to the queen
um who has been such a figure
in almost everyone's lives it's very
hard for people to remember
any life without her being on the throne
and because he was
devoted he played the part quite
extraordinarily
were well at a time when many people in
public life
disappoint uh and let um
let themselves and the country down
he put service first and he
put his efforts into a lot of great
causes including
young people and building uh the
environment and building
uh the fabric of society so you know
in every way just a remarkable person
with somebody also of their time not
somebody who was gummed up um
his uh often uh off repeated bloomers
his uh
um his perhaps um uh ill-chosen
uh words showed him to be a very human
being i mean i think people felt that
they were listening to a real human
being
you talk about the the his devotion to
the queen
and being a consort there will be some
women who will who will look at
at what has uh the tributes have been
paid to him over
the last week and say well you know
there are lots of of female consorts all
around the world who do this job
day in day out and never really uh
nobody really makes a big fuss about
this but
we have to remember don't we that it was
a very different
era in the 1940s when he took on this
role which
which is what perhaps makes it quite so
remarkable
yes i mean you can draw an analogy with
british
prime ministers they've been 55 british
prime ministers but only two of them
have been female and their in particular
consorts dennis thatcher and philip may
to marx thatcher and theresa may had an
unusual role because
the role has so much cast out uh as
a woman playing the part to the male
leader and that for a man of action i
mean he was no whip
he was an extraordinary uh action man
uh full of uh um
full of a determination to make a mark
and interested in so many
areas i mean that must have been much
more difficult for him to play a role
where he was always
behind um his wife the queen
literally behind her but also
couldn't uh speak his own mind
and always to an extent in her shadow
and and for
somebody who was so um
uh full of life larger than life such a
a big presence so full of ideas and
uh determinations to act them out in so
many ways i mean you know that was
i think remarkable uh for him
uh farm will say than in the more
conventional role of
a a woman to a male leader
he um was he a good father would you say
well you know look we don't really know
at the same time
not least with the netflix series the
crown
but in so many uh films and television
documentaries and
dramas they are the most known about
filming sorry family in the world i mean
what other family possibly has had the
uh
limelight the exposure uh that the royal
family
have had and yet also and paradoxically
we don't know
that much we think we know because we're
told by
very authoritative sources like netflix
which actually and
with the crown which actually are not so
truthful
but this is the truth and it portrays it
as the truth but
you know we we know much less uh about
what really has
happened but the strong sense from those
people who really
do know what's happened is that he was a
very good
and a very loving father
to his daughter anne and to his three
sons but also could be firm and held the
family
or helped with queen hold that family
together
so yes i think he was a good father but
i think we should
do a check on that that we really know
much less than we think we know
sir anthony selden uh interesting to
talk to you today thank you very much
for joining us
many thanks while while proceedings are
taking place here normal life across
many parts of the country is expected to
pause for the funeral
after being married to the queen for
more than 70 years the duke of edinburgh
is known to people all over
the united kingdom skystand whitehead
has been to torbay and devon
and spoken to people young and old about
how they will pay their respects
prince philip a man much admired always
upright and strong
immaculate perfectly attired he seemed
to put
no foot wrong oh that's so nice
it's a chance to remember a man they
grew up with
residents at woodland court care home in
torquay
are preparing to pay their respects to
prince philip
he always said to be upright and strong
and he wasn't
hiding or kind of um
i don't know he just seemed to be
genuine ninety-three-year-old cyril
met the prince when he visited devon
it's only just come to
light what he really did
when he was alive i mean all the things
that he was capable of
and all the visits he made to different
places
and things he did i mean
he was always in the background of the
queen and i'm sure she's going to miss
him terribly
with large gatherings still banned many
will be marking the moment
in their own way thank you very much no
problem
the babakum inn will be halting service
at three o'clock
joining the nation in a minute's silence
i should be at home with
a beer sat down with my dear wife
and we'll be watching it yeah we will be
sorry to miss him
well i should be watching it you know
and um
you know i think he'll be very emotional
to be honest
yeah i think he was wonderful man i
think just taking a moment to reflect
and i think
hopefully they will have nice weather
and it will just be a moment to sort of
stop and
take stock celebrate his life as well
nationally there will be little pomp and
ceremony
while many people will be watching the
funeral from home or raising a pint in
the local
pub for younger generations they may be
spending their saturday
preparing for his award as the duke's
legacy
lives on ashley hohn has helped run the
duke of edinburgh awards scheme
for 18 years i think the duke would want
them to
to continue doing what they're doing to
be positive
to broaden their horizons to seek new
experiences
and to remember that his legacy should
enable them to to
have access to that any events on
saturday will
be low-key just as the prince would have
wanted
regardless the nation will pause to
remember
a lifetime of service prince philip
good luck there well done david an
officer and a gentleman
dan white is sky news in torbay
well as well as living through many
moments of history the duke of edinburgh
remained often reluctantly
in the public eye until the final weeks
of his life
we're joined now by emily nash royal
editor for
hello magazine emily great to talk to
you this morning
um how do you think his passing changes
the royal family
it's going to be a huge blow for the
queen in particular obviously
she has worked without the duke aside
since 2017 when he stepped back from
public duties
but nevertheless the loss of her husband
of 73 years
is going to be absolutely devastating
for her so they will want to
rally around her and support her as best
they can
and given her own advanced stage that's
something that's been happening
increasingly over the last few years
but i think we will continue to see
senior royals joining her on engagement
where appropriate and you know spending
more and more time with her
away from away from the cameras
as you say she's known for stoicism and
we look at this lovely image of her and
prince philip together
do we do we know at all how she is
coping privately
we're hearing that she's bearing up well
she's taking daily walks
in the gardens at frogmore with her
puppies which
is must be a huge comfort to her she has
a new doggie and a corgi
one of them is actually called mick i
believe is the pronunciation
which is a reference to this beauty spot
where where sheena duke were
photographed by the cat
wessex back in 2003 so there's obviously
a lot of
reminiscing i'm sure um and spending
time where she can at a distance with
her loved ones
the amount of of of flowers that have
been brought to royal residences
and the warm tributes that have been
paid to the duke and we heard just some
of them there on a short time ago
do you think he would have been
surprised but by how warmly he
he clearly is regarded
well several members of the family have
commented on the fact that he would have
been amazed by the outpouring and of
course this is despite the royal
households
asking people politely not to leave
flowers but to instead perhaps make a
donation to a charity associated with
the duke or one of their own choice
but i think it really shows the level of
respect that people had for the duke
and also of course for the queen and
there you know
there's also a sense that so many people
in in the uk this year have
had to grieve people in these very
difficult pandemic circumstances and
there's a huge amount of sympathy
for the royal family at this moment
there will be um a lot of people
watching today uh
because they want to to mark the
occasion but there will also be those
uh rather curious to to look and see
what is going on behind the scenes of
the royal family looking at the body
language between
the dukes of cambridge and sussex
funerals can often be awkward times for
families can't they
do you think this one may be an
opportunity to build bridges
i think anything that is going on in
terms of the relationship between
william and harry will be very much
happening behind the scenes we're not
going to see any outward
displays of affection or otherwise this
is a funeral it's all about honoring
their grandfather it's about supporting
their grandmother the queen
and everyone wants the focus very much
to be on giving him the most fitting
send-off they can um that said
inevitably there's going to be a huge
amount of scrutiny this is the first
time we'll have seen
prince harry in the uk more than a year
and of course the first time we've seen
him
with his family so there's a lot of
pressure on him and on on the other
royals in fact
um to do this in the media spotlight um
i think they will be having any
discussions around
deeper family issues away from this and
after the funeral
emily nash royal editor of hello thanks
a lot for joining us this morning
well with us also this morning to review
the papers are nigel nelson political
editor of the sunday mirror and
catherine osler contributing
editor for the daily mail uh nice to see
you
uh both again um nigel kick off now
which which is the first paper that
you've picked for us this hour
we're looking inside the times now um uh
where uh the total focuses in on uh some
of the things that that
uh prince philip was uh slightly less
known for
and they're pointing out the
significance of the carriage and two
ponies that will be
in the quadrangle of windsor castle
today
now of course that um carriage driving
became
uh prince philip's sort of favorite
sport after he was forced to give up
polo at the age of 50
and he was still doing it into his 90s
now carriage driving can be
a pretty sort of dangerous occupation
especially competitively
and sophie wessex talks about how
uh on several times he had to be pulled
out of a few ditches
but it seems to show that um uh prince
philip really did
like to live life to the full um and on
the edge
so it's obviously a very fitting symbol
for what he's doing
the particular carriage uh the carriage
today
will be one he designed himself in the
same way
he designed the or helped to design the
land rover
for his funeral so what one can see how
prince philip had actually
planned this day right down to the
last letter to give himself the kind of
send-off he wanted
but without too much too much of public
fuss around it
and the pigeons nigel
and the pigeons
yes i i believe that there was uh there
was going to be the pigeons that were
released today as well
oh that's right yes so yes and and uh
that that it that is part of it again
so something that he'd ask for and
something that he that
um was that he planned all the way
through i mean everything from the
uh from that the hymns that are going to
be sung
uh right through to the uh
to the prayers and the service all of
this was something that he'd been
working on
for for some time
and catherine let's bring you in you
you've picked the mirror
uh for this hour and uh something we no
i haven't
actually i haven't seen the mirror oh i
beg your pardon
uh well sorry i'm not a contributing
editor to the daily mail either can we
just get that right
oh goodness me i'm so sorry catherine
okay i will have some stern i'll have
some stern words
after after we've we've done this um
the mirror is talking uh about the queen
and how she is hoping that the funeral
uh will will lead to healing the rift
between william and harry
um yeah i suppose a lot of people will
will hope that won't they
yes they will i mean i think with all
families we have that feeling that there
are things you've just got to sort of
overlook and move on from
and this is the perfect opportunity
isn't it for these two
to you know which we all hope that they
will
overcome this sort of terrible hurdle um
and and the chance to put it in context
with somebody who's just
led such a long life of service and also
saw so much
suffering himself when he was young um
philip having had the most desperate
childhood the mother being
taken away hospitalized for five years
the father
sort of abandoning him really um
the great aunt who was sort of murdered
by the bolsheviks in the russian
revolution i mean
not only does he span european in
history
but he has overcome sort of great pain
and you see that
the happiness he found with the queen
made up for this tragic
upbringing but you sort of hope that uh
his grandchildren will see how he could
sort of move on
from hardship and disagreement and sort
of set them an example really
nigel the male is touching on the fact
that the queen will get
her own private time she will she will
have uh
some time on her own uh with uh the
coffin before
the public funeral yes and you know how
bright this
is that um i mean the the primary person
uh
at this funeral has got to be the queen
and the family are there
to support her one hopes that prince
charles is certainly
uh doing it doing an awful lot of that
but what she wanted was just some
private time before
the coffin left windsor castle to spend
with her husband
and i think that's quite understandable
i mean she wants to actually reflect on
the 73 years of marriage that they had
the fact that he was there always uh
two steps behind her when she was out
out in public
and in privately constantly advising her
and i think to give the queen a bit of
quiet time for this is actually
incredibly important um i mean it has
been a great loss to the entire family
but to
her specifically so you could understand
that she just once
wants that brief period of reflection
before the whole funeral begins and of
course by that time
in a sense that's where we all share it
that's where the public come in
and although we can't be there
physically
uh we will be there spiritually
and catherine you know you we do think
that
all of these kind of events that the
last big event that was here
you know with prince harry's prince
harry's wedding
um that at all those events the queen
had the duke by her side and and she
will feel
that loss when she is as as the as the
bentley pulls away on on this
ceremonial procession down that that
actually
he he would have been by her side yes
isn't it touching i actually can't bear
the thought of her sitting in there
alone
as we're reading that she has to sit on
her own with a mask on that seems sort
of
so inhumane and is such a sort of
reminder of the whole sort of horror of
the past year
really um but on the other hand she has
released this wonderful picture so
i think she wants us all too to remember
how happy they were
this is a glorious you know sort of so
relaxed
sunny picture of the two of them
just you can see this is her sort of
message of saying this is when we were
happiest
they're outside he's lying on the grass
they
they could be any lovely couple
with uh better quality cashmere in the
cardigan perhaps
and that lovely trademark string of
pearls
and jane they look lovely there her
lovely sort of
tartan rug and the obvious chemistry
between them there
and nigel uh taking a look at the
express um
something that we've not touched on a
huge amount really the importance of
religious beliefs
uh for the duke of edinburgh yes that's
right and so
um he was he was brought up in the greek
orthodox church
and i think religion well religion did
play a huge part
uh in his life and also bear in mind he
was also
um console to uh the monarch who is also
the
the uh head of the church of england
and so not only was he giving her the
kind of royal advice that you would
expect
and some of presumably some
constitutional advice too
but there was also her very important
role which she took incredibly seriously
being head of the
being head of the church and obviously
that was a
key plank of monarchy and so the chur
as far as the constitutional monarchy
monarchy goes it is
um being head of the church of england
is part of
that and it is a major part so
when you look at the actual service you
can see how he planned the service
um always with one eye to what was
appropriate
so one of the great hymns coming up will
be the naval hymn
it's not the title but for those in
parallel on the sea is one of the lines
which is
the most famous it was the hymn played
at
uh president kennedy's funeral in 1963
and that was to commemorate his service
during the war in the pacific
and of course prince this is to
commemorate prince philip's wartime
service
uh what would you would he serve so
bravely
and catherine that's something that the
sun newspaper picks up uh as well
doesn't it it also has this lovely
photograph of the couple but it also
talks about the significance of the
duke's naval career
yes and that portrait there of him in
uniform
it's um the naval career is is sort of
the side of him that we seem so far away
now but he was so
sort of brave and a sort of man of
action and a man of
duty really and that ties into this idea
of his faith as well doesn't it
there he is and all his wonderful sort
of medals
looking so handsome but um with on
on the faith question i was intrigued to
read today
in the times as well or rather be
reminded
how close he is to faith you know his
own mother became
a nun and his great aunt also became a
nun
i don't know how many people can boast
two nuns in their
close uh family but so i think that
you know there are all these strands of
him we're seeing today aren't we sort of
the family man the naval man this sort
of deep
faith this representative of european
history
going through from the sort of birth on
the kitchen table in corfu to the
russian revolution
what an extraordinary life he led and
how many angles
you